with those scorching temperatures a lot
of you may have received an alert on
your phone maybe even an email from nb
energy the company is asking customers
to conserve power during the hottest
part of the day which right now is in
the late afternoon and for some fighting
the heat it's a challenge really all of
its own 8 news now reporter madison
kimbrough breaks it down for us she's
live near cambridge recreation center
with more madison
there are those trying to conserve power
while fighting rising energy costs while
others are just trying to keep cool
i saw this notice from mb energy please
turn down your ac less strain on the
grid those across the valley still
dealing with the extreme heat many
trying to find ways to cope and not
break the bank while doing so this
weekend's a big holiday weekend we are
seeing elevated temperatures across the
entire west that was josh langdon the
vice president of transmission for nv
energy he says the best advice to keep
your power bill as low as possible is
consistency when we look at when load is
gonna be the highest on the system it's
typically between five and eight pm so
you know we ask customers if they're
able to pre-cool
cool your home down a little bit
before that five o'clock hour that way
if you're able to set your thermostat to
78 degrees during the five to eight
certainly that helps also keep the
lights off for as long as possible and
for those who have pool pumps only run
your pool pump 8 to 12 hours a day
preferably after 8 pm some people we
spoke to sharing what they have to do in
order to make it through the heat some
even switching to solar and say the
amount of money they've saved from it
has made it all worth their while i used
to pay 275 to 350 a month in the times
the winter time is 110
now i'm
12 13 a month with solar it has been
high
higher than usual it makes it a little
bit harder but i'm on the payment plan
which i like very much that is helping
because it keeps it steady all year long
and if you have an electric car try to
charge it before 10 a.m or after 8 p.m
also if you're looking for a place to
cool down you can go to several of the
cooling stations we have across the
valley like the one here at cambridge
recreation center reporting live madison
kimbrough 8 news now